WANTS TO.
I SPOKE WITH MEGAN THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> THE FIRST QUESTION YOU ASKED
IN THE FIRST DEBATE, YOU HAD
WORKED ON IT AND YOUR TEAM HAD
WORKED ON IT OBVIOUSLY FOR A
LONG TIME.
DID YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS GOING
TO SET OFF?
DID YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD FOLLOW?
>> I DON'T THINK I COULD HAVE
EVER IMAGINED WHAT WOULD COME
AFTER THAT QUESTION.
I KNEW HE PROBABLY WOULDN'T LIKE
IT, RIGHT?
BECAUSE TRUMP HAD ALREADY SHOWN
HIMSELF TO BE A LITTLE SENSITIVE
TO TOUGH QUESTIONS.
>> HE HAD ALREADY CALLED YOU UP.
>> WE HAD HAD A TOUGH EXCHANGE
ON THE MONDAY BEFORE THAT
THURSDAY DEBATE.
HE WAS ANGRY ABOUT A SEGMENT I
HAD DONE THE PRIOR WEEK
INVOLVING HIS DIVORCE FROM IVANA
TRUMP.
>> ALLEGATIONS SHE HAD MADE.
>> SHE WAS CLAIMING BACK IN THE
DIVORCE HE HAD RAPED HER.
AND SHE RECANTED AND THEN THE
DAILY BEAST DID A STORY REVIVING
IT AND I PUT ON THE DAILY BEAST
REPORTER TO GIVE HIM A HARD
TIME.
30 YEARS OLD.
SHE RECANTED.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
TRUMP DIDN'T LIKE IT GETTING ANY
AIR TIME AND HE INSISTED I CALL
HIM THE MONDAY BEFORE THE
THURSDAY DEBATE AND WHEN I DID
IT DID NOT GO WELL.
>> UYOU SAID IN THE BOOK HE
THREATENED YOU.
>> HE DID.
HE WAS VERY ANGRY I AIRED THAT
SEGMENT.
AND I SAID LOOK, I DID YOU A
FAVOR.
NOBODY WAS REALLY TELLING YOU
THE OTHER SIDE OF IT.
THEY WERE JUST ACCEPTING THIS AS
THE RELEVANT STORY.
AND HE DIDN'T SEE THAT WAY.
AND MR. TRUMP, YOU DON'T CONTROL
THE STORY IN THE KELLY FILE.
HE SAID THAT'S IT.
YOU'RE A DISGRACE.
YOU OUGHT TO BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF.
AND HE SAID OH I ALMOST
UNLEASHED BY BEAUTIFUL TWITTER
ACCOUNT AGAINST YOU AND I STILL
MAY.
AND THAT WAS FOUR DAYS BEFORE
THE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE AT WHICH
I KNEW I WAS GOING TO OPEN WITH
A TOUGH QUESTION ABOUT WOMEN,
NOT ABOUT IVANA TRUMP BUT ABOUT
WOMEN.
SO GOING IN I HAD SOME NERVES
BECAUSE I HAD FEELING HE
WOULDN'T LIKE IT.
BUT I HAD TO DO MY JOB.
>> I WANT TO PLAY THAT MOMENT
JUST FOR -- NOT THAT EVERY
VIEWER IN THE WORLD HASN'T SEEN
IT ALREADY BUT LET'S JUST PLAY
IT.
>> YOU CALLED WOMEN YOU DON'T
LIKE FAT PIG, DOG, SLOBS AND
DISGUSTING ANIMALS, YOUR TWITTER
ACCOUNT --
>> ONLY ROSIE O'DONNELL.
>> NO IT WASN'T.
YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNT --
[ CROWD NOISE ]
>> THANK YOU.
>> FOR THE RECORD THIS WAS WELL
BEYOND ROSIE O'DONNELL.
>> HONESTLY MEGYN, IF YOU DON'T
LIKE IT I'M SORRY.
I'VE BEEN VERY NICE TO YOU.
ALTHOUGH I COULD BE PROBABLY NOT
BASED ON THE WAY YOU HAVE
TREATED ME BUT I WOULDN'T DO
THAT.
>> WLOOKING AT IT NOW?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WHAT I THOUGHT IN THE MOMENT
THAT WAS A VEILED SUGGEST AND HE
WAS SUGGESTING I HADN'T BEEN
NICE TO HIM.
AND I THINK AT THE TIME HE'S
GOING TO COME OF ME ON TWITTER
AND THAT WILL BE THAT.
THIS IS IN PART OF THE NATURE OF
OUR JOBS.
SO THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
HE'S BEATING UP ON ME PRETTY
GOOD IN THE DAYS AFTER THE
DEBATE AND THEN IT STARTED TO
TAKE ON A DIFFERENT TONE AND IT
STARTED TO HAVE JUST DIFFERENT
WORDS AND BY, YOU KNOW, THE
FOLLOWING NIGHT HE WAS ON WITH
DON LEMON AND MADE THOSE BLOOD
COMMENTS.
AND THAT JUST CHANGED EVERYTHING
IN -- IN THE DEBATE.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS, I WENT TO THE
BEACH TO BE WITH MY HUSBAND AND
KIDS THAT NIGHT.
I SAW DON THAT NIGHT.
NORMALLY I'M NOT WATCHING HIM.
I LOVE DON.
WE PRE TAPED THE KELLY FILE AND
TRUMP INSISTED HE GO ON AT 9:00
ON CNN ACROSS FROM ME.
YOU LET HIM ON COMMERCIAL FREE
FOR 30 MINUTES AND WE STILL BEAT
YOU.
NOT YOU.
IT WAS DON.
THAT'S WHEN HE MADE THOSE
COMMENTS.
I GOT IN THE CAR TO GO TO THE
BEACH AFTER THAT, AND I WAS
LOOKING THROUGH MY PHONE AND THE
INTERNET LOST ITS MIND OVER
THESE COMMENTS AND I SEE
POLITICIANS TWEETING OUT "I
STAND WITH MEGYN."
I'M LIKE WHAT THE?
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES AND I
THINGS WOULD NEVER BE THE SAME
AGAIN.
>> YOU HAD TO GET SECURITY.
EVEN TO GO TO DISNEY WORLD WITH
YOUR FAMILY.
>> WE HAD SECURITY THE WHOLE
YEAR.
THE THREATS GOT SO HIGH THAT IT
WAS IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY.
AND I'M NOT WALKING AROUND
NECESSARILY BELIEVING SOMEONE IS
GOING TO TRY SOMETHING BUT IT
WAS HIGH ENOUGH.
>> AND SOMEONE ACTUALLY SAID TO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IT WOULD NOT
BE GOOD FOR YOU IF MEGYN KELLY
IS KILLED.
>> MICHAEL COHEN, TRUMP'S TOP
LAWYER AND EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT WITH THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION HAD RETWEETED LETS
GUT HER," ABOUT ME.
AT A TIME WHEN THE THREAT LEVEL
WAS VERY HIGH.
AND EXACT VICE PRESIDENT OF FOX
CALLED HIM UP TO SAY YOU GOT TO
STOP THIS.
WE UNDERSTAND YOU ARE ANGRY BUT
SHE'S GOT THREE KIDS AND WALKING
AROUND NEW YORK.
AND HE DIDN'T MUCH CARE.
AND WHAT BILL SHINE SAID TO
COHEN, IF MEGYN KELLY GETS
KILLED IT IS NOT GOING HELP YOUR
CANDIDATE.
>> THE FACT THAT AN EXECUTIVE AT
YOUR COMPANY, IF THAT IS AN
ACTUAL THOUGHT THAT'S OUT THERE,
A REAL CONCERN IS INCREDIBLY
TELLING.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
SOME OF THE TACTICS ENGAGED IN
BY THOSE SUPPORTING TEAM TRUMP
WERE QUESTIONABLE.
MICHAEL COHEN, DID THAT.
COREY LEWANDOWSKI SPECIFICALLY
THREATENED ME IF I SHOWED UP AT
THE SECOND DEBATE.
AND THAT WAS THE WONE THAT TRUM
SKIPPED.
AND IT WENT ON FROM THERE.
EVEN RIGHT BEFORE DONALD TRUMP
WON HIS ONLINE SOCIAL MEDIA GUY
ISSUED ANOTHER THREAT SAYING
WAIT TILL YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS
TO HER AFTER THIS ELECTION.
>> YOU TOOK THAT IS A PERSONAL
THREAT OR A PROFESSIONAL THREAT.
>> TAKE IT THAT SERIOUSLY.
IT'S TRUMP'S GOLF CADDIE WHO NOW
RUNS HIS ONLINE SERVICES.
TRYING TO GET MY ATTENTION I
GUESS.
THE POINT IS THESE ARE NOT YOUR
NORMAL TACTICS, UNLEASHED
AGAINST A JOURNALIST WHO ASKED A
TOUGH QUESTION.
>> I DON'T THINK IT MADE ANY
DIFFERENCE BUT SOME IN READING
THE BOOK HAVE CRITICIZED YOU FOR
NOT REVEALING ALL OF THIS
CONVERSATION WITH TRUMP BEFORE
WHERE HE TALKED ABOUT UNLEASHING
HIS BEAUTIFUL TWITTER ON YOU,
KIND OF HOLDING ON TO THAT UNTIL
THE BOOK CAME OUT.
DO YOU THINK IT WOULD HAVE MADE
ANY DIFFERENCE?
>> NO.
I MEAN, DO YOU THINK IF THE
"ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" TAPE DIDN'T
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND THE 12
FEMALE ACCUSERS DIDN'T MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND THE KHAN FAMILY
AND JUDGE CURIEL, NONE OF THAT
MATTERED THAT --.
MY APPROACH WAS I WANTED TO BE
HONEST IN THAT I HAD RECEIVED
DEATH THREATS AND I HAD A GUARD
AND THE LEVEL WAS GETTING A
LITTLE DANGEROUS BUT I DIDN'T
WANT TO MAKE IT ANYMORE ABOUT
ME.
TRUMP KEPT TRYING TO MAKE IT
ABOUT ME AND THE STORY WAS ABOUT
HIM AND HILLARY CLINTON BUT IN
THE EARLY DAYS HIM AND THE OTHER
REPUBLICANS.
I WRITE IN THE BOOK THEY FELT
LIKE A HUMAN BEING WHO HAD BEEN
DROPPED INTO A SHARK TANK AND
THERE WERE PASSERS BY LOOKING IN
AND SLIGHTLY HORRIFIED AT WHAT
WAS GOING ON.
AND ALL I WANTED TO DO LAST YEAR
WAS GET MYSELF OUT OF THE SHARK
TANK.
AND IT WAS NOT GOING TO HELP TO
CHUM UP THE WATERS MORE WITH --
AND HE DID THIS AND HE DID THIS
AND HERE IS MY ROOEACTION TO
THAT."
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE THE STORY.
EVEN WHEN THE THE BLOOD COMMENTS
WE DIDN'T EVEN COVER IT ON THE
KELLY FILE.
JUST DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO TOUCH
IT.
>> ON THE ONE HAND THESE ARE
FACTS THAT MIGHT PERSUADE A
VIEWER OR INFORM A VIEWER.
THE FLIP SIDE AS JOURNALIST YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE THE STORY.
>> EXACTLY.
AND I THINK JOURNALISTICALLY IT
WASN'T A HARD CALL FOR ME.
THIS ISN'T LIKE SOMEONE CAME TO
ME AND SAID I WANT TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
ME AND DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS ME.
WE'RE UNDER NO OBLIGATION TO
REPORT OUR OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES JUST BECAUSE WE ALSO
HAPPEN TO BERELENTLESSLY.
HERE'S PART TWO OF OUR
CONVERSATION.
DONALD TRUMP WAS TALKING ABOUT
HOW HE CAN BE PRESIDENTIAL,
HOWEVER HE WANTS.
HE IS STILL TWEETING TODAY
AGAINST "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL GOVERN
LIKE?
WHAT HE'LL BE LIKE?
>> NO.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M FASCINATED TO FIND OUT.
A GREAT STORY TO COVER.
BUT YOU KNOW, LOOK.
HE IS 70 YEARS OLD.
I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF
70-YEAR-OLD MEN WHO CHANGE FROM
THE WAY THEY USED TO BE AND I
THINK GENERALLY PAST HIS
PROLOGUE.
SO I THINK HE WILL BE VERY MUCH
THE SAME ALTHOUGH HE MIGHT TRY
REIN HIMSELF IN A LITTLE BIT.
HOPEFULLY WITH RESPECT TO SOME
OF HIS DICIER RHETORIC, HE WILL
BE LIFTED UP BY THE OFFICE.
AND I'M HOPING THAT THE POWER OF
IT, AND JUST THE MAJESTY OF IT,
WILL APPEAL TO HIS BETTER
ANGELS.
>> JUST BRIEFLY, WE'RE ALMOST
OUT OF TIME.
THE ENTIRE ROGER AILES
HARASSMENT, NOT ONLY TOWARD YOU
BUT TO SO MANY WOMEN THERE.
IT IS HARD LOOKING FROM THE
OUTSIDE IN.
TO IMAGINE THAT THAT COULD HAVE
GONE ON SO LONG FROM THE TOP
DOWN.
I FEEL LIKE, IF THAT WAS
HAPPENING HERE IN THIS COMPANY,
IT IS JUST A DIFFERENT SET-UP.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE TOP HAS
THAT MUCH POWER THAT IT DID
UNDER ROGER AILES.
I SAW SOMETHING BILL O'REILLY
SAID, I GUESS HE IS PROMOTING A
BOOK SAYING, YOU COULD HAVE GONE
TO HR.
IT SEEMED LIKE ROGER AILES
CONTROLLED HR.
AND THAT'S THE SITUATION MANY
WOMEN FACE.
IT IS NOT SO EASY TO SAY, I'LL
JUST TO GO A SUPERIOR AND TELL
THEM.
>> THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING
THAT.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND I LAY IT OUT IN THE BOOK
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM OF MANY COMPANIES AND I
WANT PEOPLE TO BE ON NOTICE.
I'M HOPING CEOs WILL HEAR THIS
MESSAGE AND SAY MAYBE THIS
PROBLEM IN MY OWN COMPANY AND I
HAVE TO PROVIDE A SAFE OFF RAMP
FOR WOMEN WHO ARE NOT FEELING
SAFE TO REPORT IT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY
OUTSIDE OF THE COMPANY WHO
DOESN'T DEPEND ON THE CEO TO HIS
OR HER PAYCHECK, THE WOMEN AND
IT CAN HAPPEN TO MEN, TOO, TO
REPORT.
AT FOX NEWS IT IS VERY TRUE THAT
ROGER AILES WAS VERY MUCH A KING
OF SORTS.
AND THIS IS ALL LAID OUT IN THE
BOOK.
HE FOUNDED THE KOIRNLG
CO-FOUNDED THE COMPANY AND HE
HAD LOYALISTS PLACED THROUGHOUT
THE COMPANY.
AND HE DEMANDED LOYALTY.
O'REILLY SPEAKS OF LOYALTY.
THAT'S THE CULTURE THAT ROGER
DEMANDED, THAT THAT SHOULD BE
PLACED ABOVE ALL OTHER THINGS
AND I WOULD SUBMIT THAT IS PART
OF WHAT CREATED THE PROBLEM WE
HAD FOR SOME TIME THERE.
AND I AM VERY HAPPY THAT NOW
THAT HAS BEEN ADDRESSED, AND THE
ACTUAL OWNERS OF THE COMPANY,
THE MURDOCKS HAVE COME IN.
AS SOON AS THIS WAS BROUGHT TO
THEIR ATTENTION, THEY GOT RID OF
HIM AND HAVE CREATED A NEW
SITUATION THERE WHERE THEY'VE
MADE VERY CLEAR, THEY WANT
PEOPLE TO BE SAFE AND FEEL SAFE.
FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH, THEY WERE
ONES WHO SAID YOU SHOULD INCLUDE
THIS CHAPTER IN YOUR BOOK.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
>> YOU AND I SHARE SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
I LOST MY DAD WHEN I WAS 10.
YOUR DAD DIED WHEN YOU WERE A
SOPHOMORE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I HADN'T REALIZED THAT UNTIL I
READ THE BOOK.
AND THERE IS A QUOTE MY MOTHER
SAYS, A FATHERLESS GIRL THINKS
ALL THINGS ARE POSSIBLE, NOTHING
IS SAFE.
MY MOM GREW UP WITHOUT A FATHER.
YOU HAD A FATHER THROUGH MUCH OF
YOUR CHILDHOOD.
BUT THAT LOSS, DID IT SHAPE THE
PERSON YOU ARE NOW?
DID IT CHANGE THE PERSON YOU
WERE?
>> WELL, I KNOW YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER IS YES, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU LOSE A PARENT AT A
YOUNG AGE, IT JUST CREATES A
VOID THAT CAN NEVER BE FILLED.
YOU CAN GO ALL OVER THE WORLD
COVERING VERY DANGEROUS WARS.
AND IT IS STILL THERE.
YOU CAN STAND ON TOP OF THE NEWS
BUSINESS AND IT IS STILL THERE.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SAY IT HAS
GIVEN ME GREAT PERSPECTIVE ON
THE WORLD AND MADE ME A BETTER
PERSON AND I GUESS TO SOME
EXTENT THAT'S TRUE.
BUT I WOULD TRADE IT ALL BACK TO
HAVE ONE MORE DAY WITH HIM.
I FEEL LUCKY THAT I HAD MY DAD
UNTIL I WAS 15 AND HIS IMPRINT
ON ME WAS MADE AND IS SECURE.
BIT THAT WITH MY OWN CHIDES ARE
7, 5 AND 3.
I WORRY ABOUT MORTALITY, RIGHT?
AS DO YOU IF YOU HAVE GREAT LOSS
AT A YOUNG AGE.
>> HOW OLD WAS YOUR DAUGHTER
WHEN HE DIED?
>> HE WAS 45.
MY AGE RIGHT NOW.
>> MY DAD WAS 50 I ALWAYS
THOUGHT I WOULD DIE BY 50.
>> THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
I'M 45 NOW.
I TURN 46 ON FRIDAY.
SO I HAVE A FEW MORE DAYS.
>> I THINK YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
>> I'VE BEEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
MY 46th BIRTHDAY FOR THAT
REASON.
BUT I THINK ABOUT MORTALITY A
LOT.
AND THE THING THAT I TAKE AWAY
FROM IT, ANDERSON, IS THAT NO,
REALLY, COULD YOU DIE ANY DAY.
AND YOU CAN'T WASTE ONE SECOND
OF YOUR TIME HERE.
IT IS TOO SHORT TO BE MIRED IN
CONTROVERSY AND ACRIMONY, AND
SADNESS AND I CHANGE MY LIFE TO
TRY TO DO MORE FOR MYSELF.
AND THAT'S A GUT CHECK MOMENT
THAT I CONTINUE TO DO AND I WANT
OTHERS TO DO, TO IMPROVE THEIR
OWN LIVES.
BECAUSE WHO KNOWS?
>> ALSO, THAT YOU HAD HAD AN
ARGUMENT WITH YOUR DAD AND THAT
WAS THE LAST, YOU HAD THIS
LASTING IMAGE WITH HIM AFTER THE
ARGUMENT LAYING ON THE COUCH
ALONE LOOKING AT THE CHRISTMAS
TREE AND IT WAS LATER THAT NIGHT
THAT HE DIED.
THAT TO ME, I HAD TO STOP
READING FOR A WHILE THERE.
>> IT WAS VERY HARD TO WRITE.
IT WAS ONE CHAPTER OF THE BOOK
THAT I CAN'T GO BACK AND READ.
IT IS UPSETTING.
BUT YEAH.
WE HAD AN ARGUMENT THE NIGHT HE
DIED.
AND WE ALMOST NEVER ARGUED.
HE NEVER HAD A HARSH WORD FOR
ME.
I WAS BEING A BRATTY TEENAGE
HERE WANTED A NICE CLASS RING.
I WANTED A NICER ONE THAN WE
COULD AFFORD AND HE TOLD ME WE
COULDN'T.
I KEPT COMPLAINING.
HE TURNED AND WALKED OUT OF THE
KITCHEN.
AND IT WAS THE LAST EXCHANGE I
EVER HAD WITH MY DAD.
I STORMED UP TO MY ROOM AND
THERE HE WAS SITTING ON THE
COUCH, STARING AT THE CHRISTMAS
TREE.
I DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING TO HIM.
I WENT INTO MY BEDROOM.
THE NEXT THING WAS MY SISTER
BURST INTO MY ROOM AND SAID WAKE
UP.
DADDY HAD A HEART ATTACK.
HE NEVER REVIVED.
WITHIN THREE HOURS WE WERE AT
THE HOSPITAL NEXT TO HIS BED